les brasseries artisanales sont en
pleine expansion en ile-de-france il en
existe plus de 90 et le syndicat des
brasseurs de france s'attelle à
développer le tourisme brassicole avec
la création d'un site internet sur
lequel on retrouve une carte interactive
des brasseries
alors j'ai cherché et comptabilisé une
douzaine de brasserie dans les yvelines
de quoi se faire un vrai circuit partons
à la découverte du département à travers
ces artisans de la transformation du
houblon
[Musique]
première découverte aux portes de la
plaine de versailles la brasserie au
club de bois d'arcy propose des bières
veille en barriques sébastien va nous
raconter tout ça o clock existe depuis
2015 et deux ans après sa création la
bande de copains a voulu tester le
vieillissement des bières en barriques
débarré qui ont déjà servi pour du
whisky du ce au terme du cognac et
autres spiritueux et qui peuvent
transmettre leur histoire en résulte la
gamme baden power nous ce qui nous plaît
énormément là dedans c'est cette espèce
d'effet surprise c'est dès le jour de la
livraison et même le jour de la commande
c'est à dire qu'on va appeler la
tonnellerie
on leur dit qu'est ce que vous avez
dispense moment et nous envoie une liste
et puis on va choisir un peu au hasard
parfois ce qui ce qu'ils ont et le jour
de la livraison c'est ouvrir les
bouchons met le nez dedans et se dire
ouais c'est ça ça va être génial
aujourd'hui la brasserie dispose d'une
cinquantaine de barrick dans lesquelles
les pierres vieillissent entre 6 et 18
mois
dernière cuvée la youri is une
collaboration avec une brasserie russe
une bière à 13° vieilli dans une
barrique de cognac avec des copeaux de
noix de coco torréfié
[Musique]
pour notre arrêt en vallée de chevreuse
nous sommes plus précisément au
perray-en-yvelines pour découvrir la
brasserie de la vallée de chevreuse
elle compte une gamme d'une douzaine de
bières et parmi elles des terres bio
d'abord installée à bonnel emmanuel est
l'un des premiers à s'être lancée dans
les yvelines en 2008 une première année
en bière conventionnel avant de passer
au bio
je me suis laissé convaincre par un
copain tout simplement qui pour lui
toute sa démarche vers le bio était
tournée vers les générations futures
alors on en pense qu'on en veut mais
c'était c'était sa démarche et
après peu après cette discussion il a eu
des jumeaux et donc samassa va un petit
peu fait réfléchir et après j'ai
converti la bière en bio la vol céleste
à ses consommateurs réguliers la
brasserie a déménagé de bonnet lo
perray-en-yvelines il ya deux ans pour
s'agrandir de 200 elle est passée à 2000
mètres carrés
[Musique]
très réactif chez toussaint ils ont su
trouver la solution pour ne pas perdre
le stock des fûts destinés au bar la
brasserie prépare dès janvier février
ses stocks pour l'été on s'est vite dit
qui serait difficile de passer ses fûts
avec le confinement ce qu'on connaissait
pas la date la date de fin et du coup
est venue l'idée de ces petits fûts qui
nous permettait de transvaser les fugues
de bach amphi 2 5 litres utilisable par
le grand public
ces petits fûts connaissent un tel
succès qu'ils vont verser parmi les
produits proposés brasserie tout ça a
été créé en 2016 dans un esprit familial
avant d'avoir sa ligne d'embouteillage
ce sont les propres parents de clément
qui s'en charge et à la main aujourd'hui
c'est bien rond même une place de choix
dans la cave spécialisé en vins naturels
de son grand frère
notre parcours de bière tourisme dans
les yvelines s'achève et c'est alors
bien sûr tout ceci est à consommer avec
modération mais on peut pas s'empêcher
de terminer tout ça avec une petite
dégustation
[Musique]